so what station B is aiming to do is to
develop a platform a system that will
transform programming biology from what
is currently a process of trial and
error to something that systematic and
predictable and that requires bringing
together many different pieces of the
puzzle in programming biology there is a
sort of standard design build test learn
cycle so we're trying to combine these
different stages of programming into an
integrated platform you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen heusinger when we think of
information processing systems we often
think of computers but we ourselves are
made up of information processing
systems trillions of them also known as
the cells in our bodies while these
cells are robust they're also
extraordinarily complex and not
altogether predictable wouldn't it be
great asks dr. Andrew Phillips head of
the biological computation group at
Microsoft Research in Cambridge if we
could figure out exactly how these
building blocks of life work and harness
their power with the rigor and
predictability of computer science to
answer that he spent a good portion of
his career working to develop a system
of intelligence that can literally
program biology today dr. Phillips talks
about the challenges and rewards
inherent in reverse engineering
biological systems to see how they
perform information processing he also
explains what we can learn from
stressed-out bacteria and tells us about
station B a new end-to-end platform his
team is working on that aims to reduce
the trial and error nature of lab
experiments and helps scientists turn
biological cells into super factories
that could solve some of the most
challenging problems in medicine
agriculture the environment and more
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Andrew Phillips welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me it's a pleasure to
be here so you're the head of the
biological computation group at MSR in
Cambridge what's going on in your group
broad strokes what big problems are you
trying to solve what gets you up in the
morning well one of the things we're
really working on is trying to
understand how biological systems
compute so biological systems like
living cells they actually perform
information processing but they compute
by means that we don't quite fully
understand so my team is working on
trying to reverse engineer how these
living systems biological systems
perform information processing I want to
unpack the big suitcase of biological
computation a bit more as you've noted
programming biology it's not new but
there are some new things that are going
on so give us a short primer on
biological computation where did this
all get started and why and where are we
today so one of the things we're
focusing on is trying to understand how
to program biological systems but to do
that you need to understand how these
systems function if you want to try to
fix a car but you didn't understand how
the components worked you couldn't just
randomly change those components and
expect the car to work so in order to
program a system we need to understand
how it's working and in our case we need
to understand how these cells are
computing now as the species we've been
using cells to do things for us for
thousands of years we've used yeast to
make bread or to brew beer and then
several decades ago we were able to
reprogram microorganisms to produce
medicines things like insulin and now
we're taking this to the next level as a
field as a discipline and programming
organisms to do much more sophisticated
things make much more complex medicines
fuels and materials so understanding how
systems compute is an important step to
being able to program them more
effectively when did somebody discover
hey we could actually make this do
something for us or make it do something
different than it does was that an aha
moment or an
accident or did people try to start
manipulating biology well I think the
first example of programming and
microorganism to make a medicine in this
case insulin was in the 70s and this is
as we started to understand more about
DNA about how cells work and then more
recently we've been able to sequence the
human genome and now we've been able to
write DNA we've been able to write genes
so there's been this steady progress in
technology that sort of underpinned our
ability to program biology hmm in fact
there's been an exponential growth in
our ability to read DNA and also to
write DNA and then more recently we've
had some transformations in our ability
to edit DNA through things like CRISPR
so we have this underlying technology
that's allowing us to manipulate DNA
read write and edit it and that's also
underpin this technological growth in
our ability to program biology well
let's talk about those underpinnings for
a minute there are some pieces that need
to be in place before we can make
significant progress you've alluded to
DNA are there other pieces that we
really need to understand before we can
move forward and make biology work for
us more specifically and even more
predictably and less expensively well
yeah I mean there's still a lot we have
to learn in terms of understanding how
biological systems function so
biological systems are highly complex
they're massively parallel they're
probabilistic in many ways it closer to
analog computing systems than the
digital ones that we're familiar with so
we still have a lot of work to do to
reverse engineer these systems so that's
the challenge understanding how these
systems work another challenge is that
we still lack a way of doing biological
experiments systematically and reliably
a lot of experiments are done manually
they're time-consuming the error-prone
and in fact recent studies have shown
that most biological experiments are not
even reproducible and then the final
challenge is that we actually lack the
technology stack for programming biology
there isn't really a systematic way in
many ways programming biology is sort of
similar to the early days of trying to
program silicon before the advent of
high-level languages and the fundamental
theory of computing that we sort of take
for granted
so we're sort of still in the days of
almost punch cards and very basic
programming technology that's funny
so you alluded just now to our much more
advanced ability to read and write DNA
how has that impacted the growth in
programming biology and what limitations
do we still face aside from the things
that you've just mentioned in terms of
what we don't understand yeah so this
technology has been hugely important and
has enabled the progress that we've seen
to date in prog biological organisms so
by that I mean reading writing and
editing DNA but on its own is not enough
so we can read an entire genome but we
still don't understand what most of it
means and we can write an entire gene
but we're still unable to predict how
that gene will behave inside a living
organism and we can now edit DNA with
really high precision with technologies
like CRISPR
but we're still unable to predict the
consequences of those edits so really
we're still in a situation where
programming biology is done by trial and
error so what is it about biological
systems that confounds our ability to
program them we're coming at this from a
computer science angle so we're
basically talking about using
programming languages to compile
biological algorithms to DNA code
instead of binary talk about the
differences between how biological cells
operate and how computer programs
operate what are the unique challenges
that scientists face in programming
biology so yeah essentially biological
programs operate in a fundamentally
different manner to traditional silicon
based programs that were used to writing
so you can think of a traditional
computer program more like a recipe
where you have a list of actions that
happen in a particular order you know do
step one in step two and maybe you
repeat this n times whereas biological
systems they actually compute via
fundamentally different means so it's
more like a chemical soup where you have
thousands of proteins interacting in
parallel in a noisy fashion and many of
these interactions can go wrong with
some probability but yet out of all that
noise emerges a fairly robust algorithm
that is used to compute things like when
should a cell divide or how should an
immune system respond to a foreign
invader or even things like the internal
body clock which is essentially a
combination of genes and protein
interaction
that computes a 24-hour period fairly
reliably so these algorithms are
actually very complicated for us to
understand because we're not used to
that we're still trying to
reverse-engineer them less I got noise
for a second you've just mentioned it
and you've recently published a paper
about how bacteria use noise to survive
stress so tell us about this what
insights did you gain from this research
about noise and bacteria and what are
the implications for the work that
you're doing so this is one of many
examples actually of how we as a team at
Microsoft Research are collaborating
with leading scientists in many
different fields in universities so this
particular collaboration with the
University of Cambridge was with James
Locke the Department of Biochemistry
Sainsbury Laboratory and a joint PhD
student Microsoft funded on potage and
we were looking together at trying to
understand the role of noise in how
bacteria survive stress now stress in
this case is not an emotional response
it's more about you know if the bacteria
are in adverse conditions so you give
them hydrogen peroxide or some kind of
dangerous compound that could
potentially kill them how do they
survive and this work you know ohm did
most of the experiments for this and we
look together at the computational
modeling side is trying to understand
how bacteria can actually anticipate
stress and actually survive and it turns
out that bacteria are growing in a noisy
fashion and they're also turning on a
stress response sort of randomly and
this noisy growth and noisy stress
response a coupling so the bacteria that
are growing slowly are actually more
able to survive the stress and also some
fraction of the bacteria randomly decide
to get into the state so that if a
stress happens to be applied in the
future they actually survive and so this
is a really kind of interesting example
of how noise can perform a useful
function for bacterial systems but more
generally it's one of the examples of
how we're trying to understand the
mechanisms that bacteria and other
living cells use in order to survive and
process information more generally so
you're talking about bacteria writ large
and we know that some bacteria is
actually really really bad and we don't
want that to survive is there a way to
parse out ham when am you know
provide some noise and stress to the
bacteria that I want to survive well yet
essentially trying to understand how a
system works then we can try and direct
it reprogram it depending on what we
wanted to achieve so if it's a dangerous
infection that we're trying to eliminate
then we can understand where we want to
preserve that system for example trying
to overcome things like antibiotic
resistance and if it's a beneficial
bacteria for example the bacteria that
lives inside our gut we want those
bacteria to survive because they provide
tremendous benefits to us and so
understanding the mechanism is that
bacteria use in general can help us
determine what strategies to use in the
beneficial case and in the harmful case
[Music]
what are the most promising applications
of the research you're doing what is the
field hoping for before we start talking
about some specific things that you are
doing at Cambridge yeah it's a really
exciting field this often referred to as
synthetic biology where the goal is to
program biological systems more
systematically using engineering based
principles and so this field as a whole
is moving forward rapidly and there are
many applications that are actually
currently making excellent progress and
there many potential future applications
the ones that excite me most are
actually in the medical field biologics
these are drugs made by reprogram
organisms and they are essentially the
fastest growing sector in the
pharmaceutical industry and they account
for over half of industry revenues and
our new drug approvals and there are
actually some of the most powerful
treatments we have for diseases like
cancers that many traditional drugs
chemical based drugs are not able to
treat and so these biologics they're too
complex to be made by ordinary chemical
means and so instead they're made by
genetically program organisms that act
as living factories and biologics also
include sort of more advanced treatments
one example is cell therapy where you
can actually reprogram a patient's
immune cells to target specific cancers
and there's an example of a company
Oxford by America with whom we're
working that in partnership with
Novartis they've developed the first
living cancer drug which essentially
reprograms a patient's immune cells to
fight cancer with 80% patients in
complete remission the first trials so
that's one of the most exciting areas
but it also many other areas agriculture
is another one
so nitrogen fertiliser is responsible
for five percent of global greenhouse
emissions and half of the fertilizers
washed away causing toxic pollution and
this company called pivot bio they've
essentially reprogrammed soil microbes
to transfer nitrogen directly to the
plant roots without emitting these
greenhouse gases and with almost no
pollution so very little is washed away
these program microbes are actually
performing extremely well in recent
trials in the field
then there's a lot of potential for
other industries as well like
construction so the cement industry
accounts for about 5% of global carbon
dioxide emissions and there's a company
called Bao Mason this reprogrammed
microbes to produce cement at ambient
temperature so they can get rid of most
of these emissions and then textiles so
the textile industry generates about a
fifth of the world's industrial water
pollution mainly in developing countries
and this company called polar if X is an
early startup but they've actually
programmed microbes to produce some
fixed ice to fabric using ten times less
water than traditional dyeing methods
and then there's a whole lot of other
examples for instance in the chemical
industry so the company called Jean
America they've actually program
microbes to produce fully biodegradable
plastics and so now they can produce
biodegradable plastics a scale to
replace things like plastic bags and
then you look at the textile industry as
a whole we can program East to produce
leather or even spider silk so there's a
whole range of technologies that are
really exciting so this research is
incredibly ambitious takes a lot of
brains a lot of expertise will talk
about partners in a minute but I want to
talk right now about the main project
that you're working on is called station
B so we've identified some of the
problems inherent in programming biology
as well as some of the sort of
individual trial and error attempts to
solve them but this is a much more
comprehensive run at this he'll tell us
all about station B what is it how is it
different what's it going to do so
station B is really motivated by all the
applications that I just talked about
right and so there's this tremendous
potential but yet they're these
tremendous you know barriers to
achieving that potential and the one I
mentioned is just the fact that
programming biology is primarily done by
trial and error and so you know there
are many aspects to that that we can try
and address so what station B is aiming
to do is to develop a platform a system
that will transform programming biology
from what is currently a process of
trial and error to something that
systematic and predictable and that
requires bringing together many
different pieces of the puzzle in
programming biology there's this sort of
standard design build test learn cycle
so we're trying to combine these
different stages of programming into an
integrated platform
and in the design phase we're developing
biological programming languages and
compilers I can take programs written in
a language that people can understand
and compile them down into DNA you know
code that living systems can execute in
the test phase we're partnering with a
company called synthase actually
specialized in lab automation they're
one of the leading lab automation
companies and what they're doing is
developing device drivers and an
infrastructure layer to actually make it
much easier to program lab equipment lab
robots to do experiments more
systematically and reproducibly by
digitally encoding those experiments as
programs and synthase is actually built
on top of Microsoft is your Internet of
Things technology so I've got design
we've got build you've got test and in
the learn face or actually combining
expertise in machine learning to analyze
the data in order to learn models of how
biological systems compute so we're sort
of proposing models using machine
learning to actually refine our
hypotheses and then storing that
information that knowledge inside a
knowledge base so that as we go around
this design build test learn cycle we're
actually getting better at understanding
how to program biological systems and so
the key point here is to try and bring
together these different technologies
and over the past decade almost we've
been working on individual methods
individual pieces individual programming
languages and now we're station B we're
trying to bring together the individual
methods we've been developing and you
know some of the breakthroughs that
we've made into this integrated system
that will help our partners and
collaborators become better at
programming biological systems so where
is this now it's very much still in the
research phase yeah that's right we do
have a research prototype of this
platform that we've developed the next
phase now is to actually work very
closely with a selected number of
partners in order to develop and apply
this platform to specific challenges so
let's talk about those partners for a
minute you've got them across industry
and academia who are you working with
and what kinds of things might we expect
to see well we continue to work with
many university collaborators around the
on a range of specific research projects
but really the first University
collaboration involving station B is a
platform is with Princeton they'll be
working with Professor Bonnie Bassler a
head of the molecular biology department
and also professor in it wind green
about physicist by training on
understanding the mechanisms of biofilm
formation so biofilms are essentially
surface associated colonies of bacteria
and they actually kill as many people as
cancer and they are one of the leading
causes of microbial infection worldwide
and also an important cause of
antibiotic resistance which was recently
highlighted by the World Health
Organization as a growing crisis that we
cannot ignore so what we're trying to do
is use the station B platform to
understand how biofilms form what are
the mechanisms that they use and the
platform as to say well combined
programming languages and analysis
methods to allow us to program microbial
systems perturb these microbial systems
measure the effects of those
perturbations try and reverse engineer
how bacteria communicate and how they
interact in order to form these biofilms
and then by understanding the mechanisms
of formation we can seek to disrupt
these biofilms and potentially hopefully
in the future that would give rise to
new forms of treatment and by biofilm
you mean slime yeah that's right let's
get real so that's fascinating because
one of the things we think about when we
think about what kills people and what's
bad is disease but where does the
disease come from so that's what you're
addressing right is if we can get to the
source we can control more of it that's
right I mean for many years you know the
pharmaceutical industry has almost been
forced to do things again by trial and
error there is a disease and we have a
hunch as to what molecules we want to
target and then you know pharmaceutical
companies and researchers would just
test the whole range of random compounds
see which ones stick and then maybe put
those in mice and then maybe eventually
put them in people without often knowing
how these drugs are working
but now as treatments become more
sophisticated and as we get better at
treating disease it's becoming
increasingly important to understand how
the treatments work and that requires an
understanding of how the disease or the
pathogen works hmm this is so cool
because if you look at science over the
eons it's been what happens if I put
this with that and your efforts here are
to codify and shrink down that process
of trial and error by using computer
science that's right and I do what
emphasize you know there's a whole field
and there are many people around the
world working on this and we're a part
of that field you know Microsoft we do
have expertise many years of research
and breakthroughs in biological
programming languages compilers machine
learning methods but we're part of this
growing field that's really trying to
solve some of the most important
challenges facing humanity so who are
some other partners that you're working
with in station B and what are you
working on with them so our main other
partner is Oxford biomedical and as I
mentioned briefly before they
essentially have developed technology to
reprogram patient's own immune cells to
target specific cancers and they are the
first company together with Novartis to
actually have FDA approval for this type
of treatment and in clinical trials 80%
of patients who actually had no hope of
surviving many of them had had bone
marrow transplant or had gone through
chemotherapy 80% of these patients when
they received this treatment were in
complete remission and the treatment has
also been approved by the NHS National
Health Service in the UK but at a cost
of two hundred eighty two thousand
pounds per patient and so these
treatments are really expensive and part
of our collaboration with Oxford
biomedic is to try and work with them to
improve the ways in which these
treatments are produced and try by
understanding how the cells are
functioning how the cells are producing
the treatments to actually bring down
the costs but also to help with the
development in the future of new
treatments there's a whole range of
diseases including Jesus
Parkinson's disease and others which
could benefit from this type of
technology that Oxford by America and
others in the field of developing and so
we've just started a collaboration with
Oxford by America to help improve the
way that these treatments are produced
and to look at ways of producing new
treatments as well what we're doing is
working with this company in particular
to try and help improve their existing
technology and bring down the costs and
allow them to develop new technologies
which in turn will be subject to the
rules and regulations of the industry
Oxford by America their treatment is
saving lives today
and with our station B platform we are
looking forward to working closely with
them to help save more lives more
[Music]
all right Andrew with all the promising
futures including winning the war on
slime your research is at its core about
altering biology via computer coding
what could possibly go wrong
good question well as I said before we
are very careful about who we work with
and the two main partners we're working
with for station B Princeton and Oxford
by America they are subject to you know
very stringent regulations than they
abide by and they've been doing this
work for many years and as I say as new
treatments are developed then those
treatments will go through the same or
even more rigorous approval processes so
we're really working with the right
partners to try and help them be more
productive so that's one point what's
also very encouraging is that
governments are taking this technology
very seriously and they're the ones who
are setting the agenda and they've been
councils appointed by various
governments to study synthetic biology
and the desire to program biology more
effectively and this situation is
constantly being monitored and as
regulations are produced then our
partners will abide by those so yeah we
have to be very careful in that respect
well let me push in a little bit there
because we have so many best-case
scenarios in front of us on how this
technology could be really helpful in
our lives but I can think of several if
not numerous outcomes that might fall in
the dystopian bucket of technical
advance so even as you think about how
governments and agencies can try to
regulate this is there anything that
keeps you up at night what keeps me up
at night right now is all these
challenges we face as a species
you know sustainability and disease and
environmental pollution that's what
currently keeps me up at night and I see
this technology is a way as I mentioned
in many of the applications I talked
about as a way to solve so many of these
challenges hmm
there's also another issue which is that
you know what if we do nothing
so nature itself interestingly enough is
constantly evolving natural organisms
are constantly mutating viruses amuse
dating so nature is producing new
diseases naturally constantly and we're
seeing in some cases resistance to
medicines like antibiotics that have
saved hundreds of millions of lives
these systems are now becoming resistant
to antibiotics and so we need to find
new treatments and so if we do nothing
there is a real danger that a global
pandemic breaks up that nature has
produced through random mutation that we
are unable to treat because we don't
understand how these systems work and
we're not able to develop the treatment
in time or as these existing treatments
start to fail because nature again is
mutating and smarter now competing us
and going around our treatments if we
don't understand how to develop new
treatments quickly enough then we're
real trouble so I think there's a real
threat from nature itself but there's
another important issue as well which is
you know as I mentioned before about the
drug industry traditionally doing things
by trial and error and now we see this
new potential still being done by trial
and error it's going to be increasingly
important to do things in a predictable
way to do things systematically to be
able to understand what we're doing I
think with computer models programming
languages machine learning being able to
close that loop between models and
experiments we'll be able to predict
more and more accurately the outcomes of
the modifications we're making so that
we can be very careful about not making
the wrong modifications and if we get
better and better at counteracting the
bioterrorist that is nature which is
constantly throwing things at us we'll
also get better and better at
counteracting human endeavors which are
trying to be malicious because now we
understand that if a random mutation
happens or deliberate mutation happens
we'll be able to counteract it so I
think it's going to be really important
to stay on top of this Andrew tell us
about yourself and your academic
background you're originally from
Barbados West Indies
you went to Toulouse France and now
you're in Cambridge
you've had quite a journey what got you
started and how did you end up at
Microsoft Research okay so I was always
interested in robotics engineering I was
fascinated by machines that people
design so I studied engineering in
Toulouse France and then I got really
interested in programming and so I
learned computer science in Cambridge
did a PhD at Imperial College in London
and studied concurrent parallel computer
systems so programming languages for
programming these parallel systems the
theory and also the implementation
techniques and their while at Imperial
limit Lukic or Delhi a scientist that
Microsoft research at the time and he
was of a similar background but a leader
in the field of concurrent programming
languages and he was applying these to
study biological systems which are
massively concurrent and I got
fascinated by this and so I did an
internship with Microsoft Research and
then I was hired by a Steven Emmett who
was leading a team at the intersection
of computer science and biology and
that's how I got started since then I've
been trying to develop methods from
computer science but there are a
specific to biology and it's been a lot
of cross-fertilization there so did you
actually come up with the programming
language to translate from binary code
to DNA code as it were well she I had an
intern very very talented intern back in
2009 Michael Peterson and we worked
together on this very preliminary
prototype of a programming language
which he coated up and then we published
the paper together and designed the
language together and since then we've
sort of been evolving and extending the
language and more importantly trying to
bridge the gap between what you write on
a computer what gets executed in a Cell
I'm making sure that that's more and
more predictable so we started a long
time ago I think we still have a long
way to go in the future
but we're making progress is anyone else
using your language so we've developed
actually three main my coaches one for
programming systems at the molecular
level
another at the genetic level and a third
at the network level so far we've had
most success at the molecular level
because it's much more predictable this
is sort of programming DNA systems to
compute and so yes there are a number of
people who've used that language I've
also taught some courses at this
international genetically engineered
machines competition on using our
genetic programming language so yeah we
do have people using our software but we
are actually very careful about who we
collaborate with and using the software
mostly internally do you have names for
the languages yeah we have one it's
called visual DSD DNA strand
displacement another one is visual gec
for genetic engineering cells and the
third is rain reasoning about
interaction networks I love that so
every so often I get a researcher on the
show who has such an interesting side
quest that we have to go there I'm not
even gonna ask you about all the things
you've done like snowboarding kite
surfing Chinese kickboxing Thai boxing
you should like this extreme guy but
you're a qualified ballroom dance
instructor and you're a member of the
Imperial College dance team while you
were getting your PhD so I just I have
to know how did you get involved with
this Strictly Ballroom set okay so how I
actually got started was I was sort of
looking forward to my wedding and wanted
to make sure that I did a good job on
the first dance so I thought I would
attend a couple of ballroom dancing
classes but then I got invited to
audition and it all took off from there
so I was part of the university team we
used to travel around the country and
compete with other universities it was
great fun we used to have lessons you
know and practice several times a week
and I really enjoyed it and then you
know because we had to do all of that I
thought I could as well take the exams
that qualify you to be a ballroom dance
instructor and so I did those sadly I'm
not so much involved anymore that was a
long time ago yeah my best dance was the
waltz and also the foxtrot and I really
enjoyed it
I still do the earth style so from time
to time all right
as we close I like to ask my guests to
leave our listeners with some parting
thoughts
so sometimes it's advice sometimes it's
wisdom sometimes it's predicting the
future what would you say to aspiring
researchers who might be interested in
the field of computational biology what
are the big open problems and what kinds
of people do we need to help solve them
well the first thing to notice is that
it's really an interdisciplinary
endeavor so we need mathematicians
computer scientists people with
expertise in machine learning
programming languages lab automation and
of course biologists experimental
biologists so I would say that if you're
looking to get into this field it's
really important to at least understand
the intersection of these different
disciplines or a subset of these
disciplines someone who can do
biological experiments but understands
the principles of say machine learning
could really help make some of these
exciting breakthroughs at the
intersection of the two fields the other
thing is that I really think that
programming biology is going to
transform many of the industries that
are in existence today I think it's a
sort of an underpinning technology that
will help transform medicine food energy
and build the foundations for future bar
economy that's based on sustainable
technology so it's really going to be an
exciting field and I would encourage
anyone with an interest join come help
us factly Andrew Phillips thank you for
coming on the show today and sharing all
the insights in programmable biology my
pleasure
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Andrew Phillips
and how researchers are using computer
science techniques to program biological
systems visit microsoft.com
[Music]